attachment Emil chachki Mon Becca's icky
all across the country Michael Lowell
the stories are all the same oil wells
in an athletic Craig Walsh intelligent
out of Tolkien well lights college
student goes missing family and friends
launch a massive search weeks or months
later the young man is discovered
drowned in more than forty cases the
deaths are blamed on a drunken accident
except for one Chris Jenkins the death
of Chris Jenkins in Minneapolis is the
only one where the cause of death was
changed from an undetermined drowning to
homicide
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey everybody it's us again and it's
episode 68 I think yeah yes a smiley
face murders yeah this is kind of an
interesting one I actually didn't know
much about this and this was also a
listener request it's weird because
we've done shows about serial killers
before you know we do a lot of true
crime type of shows this is kind of the
first time that I know of that we're
doing one about a theoretical serial
killer okay yeah I guess the Atlanta
Ripper was kind of a theoretical serial
killer because they don't know if that
was all one dude or not yeah before we
get get off to end this too much this is
just a disclaimer whenever we do these
serial killer things these are not the
definitive source of information about
these cases these are introductions to
this case to our regular listeners okay
at home
you know a lot we get guys on there oh
you know this part was wrong where this
tiny detail was wrong you know these are
huge cases they're very detailed Jenni
has to do a lot of research the chances
of there being an error you know are
pretty high pretty high but mostly just
do these do these to point them out to
our regular listeners and they can go
check things out for themselves if
they're interested well I'm like I said
I'm kind of glad that someone suggested
this because I didn't really know a lot
about it and the more I looked into it
it's kind of fascinating and really I'm
not sure where I stand on it which is
also kind of interesting thing because
there's sort of you know there's
evidence foreign against so and
evidently I didn't really know but
evidently like online there's either
people that are like super into yes this
is like a serial killer or people that
are just as adamantly no it's not a
serial killer and you know never the
twain shall meet
again and I've never even heard this and
this one like I said I don't really fall
on either side and I'm just gonna say
that in the outset because one I don't
know like you know I did several days
research on it and stuff like that but
you know it's such a huge vast
complicated case in such a complicated
theory and there are so many cases
involved that I'm not gonna say that I
think one or the other okay
I mean I lean toward one thing but I but
I'm not gonna say I know absolutely
nothing about this is the first time I'm
hearing about it this is Jamie's baby
but just from what you're telling me
what sounds like is somewhere there was
a bunch of homicides they think maybe
maybe a serial killer did is that what
you're talking about
well not well the thing is that a lot of
them are not necessarily classified as
homicides a lot of them are clubbed most
of them are classified accident okay
yeah but some people are saying that
they aren't accidents they are homicide
and that it's one or a gang of people
doing it okay so this should be
interesting
yeah all right obviously is pretty fast
when do the plugs before we get into it
yeah and they're like I said there's
only a couple of my book the faceless
villain obviously is out print and ebook
if you bought it and liked it please
read leave a review because that really
helps out the audiobook has been
uploaded I had a slight minor issue with
just the sample file but I fixed that so
hopefully if there's no other problems
that should be on sale very soon we did
a new movie review if you haven't seen
it it was of the Omega Man No maybe with
the hist
yes actually you know what what I was
thinking about I was calling him the
Hess right yeah I think I'm a renaming
all right into what the chocolate
Cheston the chipster Cheston accent yeah
I like that better Cheston the Cheston
yeah cuz then he can like hang with the
crustle henceforth you shall be known as
Cheston which actually in in light of
the Omega Man is actually pretty apropos
because he does walk around shirtless
and alert him out in that yeah yeah he's
got weird describe Leo hair and that was
back in the old 70s you didn't really
have to be all that pops yeah with no
shirt on yeah just fine look at John
Wayne I mean then you look at you know
people were a lot more forgiving yeah
these are photoshop nowadays everyone
has to look super perfect and I got
Cheston and you're like that's
considered like an alpha male you know
tough guy damn he's a little stringy
stringy looking and sunken in looking
[ __ ] he's gonna come kick your ass when
he's old man he thought he was dead I
think chest is dead I'm not sure I
guessed instead we'll see I don't I
don't think he's that I think he's not
okay
and also if you would like to support
the show we have a patreon page as
probably most of you know by now and
it's patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast if you would rather just give a
one-time donation rather than a monthly
donation then you can go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there is a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account alright so
let's get into this smiley face murders
thing like I said this was a reader
request a reader request listener
request this was a listener of course
why do I always say that I don't know
cuz I guess cuz I'm used to writing
books and [ __ ] yeah so yeah so this was
a listener request and like I said I
didn't know [ __ ] all about this until I
started looking into it was it cool yeah
it's actually really easy alright let's
check and like I said there's a lot of
[ __ ] about it alright I'm ready now this
theory I'm bracing myself you're bracing
yourself yes means chancellor sitting
here okay so yeah this theory was
actually it was first put forward in
2008 by two former New York City
homicide detectives huh they had since
retired and they went into business as
private investigators together alright
so now I had the institutional freedom
to think for themselves and it was right
at a time even though that they didn't
go public with theory until 2008 but the
run of cases that they think are
involved in this whole thing actually
started around 1997 okay
although the first case that got them
thinking that maybe there was a serial
killer at large happened in 2002 okay
this is real pretty recent stuff that
yeah
and this some people think that it's
still going on okay so okay my interest
yeah so now while they were
still working for the NYPD there was a
guy named Christopher Jenkins and he was
a student at the University of Minnesota
it was Halloween night of 2002 he was
wearing like kind of a weird like Native
American kind of costume and looked kind
of looked like a jumpsuit that was like
brown suede or something like a feathery
headdress I think so he went to a keg
party and then he went to a place called
the lone tree Bar and Grille in downtown
Minneapolis with some of his friends
they got there about 10:30 now according
to some of his friends and other
witnesses and stuff like that he wasn't
super drunk but evidently he like
spilled the drink on the front of his
costume and it made it look like he peed
himself okay yeah so one of the bouncers
was like hey that dude peed himself and
kind of kicked him out of the bar yeah
and he didn't have any of his stuff like
ever having his phone in his wallet or
anything and it was like pretty cold out
so you know he didn't have his coat his
wallet or anything like that so he
didn't have his car keys or his
apartment keys so he gets kicked out of
the bar and vanishes off the face of the
earth
damn no one sees him again huh so they
report him missing I think it was his uh
either his roommate or roommates or
whatever reported him missing and they
think well maybe he was drunker than we
thought maybe he tried to walk home over
the Hennepin bridge they're the parents
they hired like a private investigator
and they had all the surveillance
footage like around there checked and
everything like that and they couldn't
find any side of him so four months
after Chris Jenkins disappeared they
found his body in the Mississippi River
and it was kind of frozen in there you
could see it from the 3rd Avenue Bridge
now at first the cops thought well he
must have just fallen off the bridge or
you know but he was dropped that night
or he was trying to walk home or
anything like that or he committed
suicide right now his family were like
nah that that's doesn't make any sense
it also seemed strange that he would
like fall off the bridge because if you
see there are pictures of the Hennepin
bridge like on line one he never turned
up on any surveillance footage in that
entire
is covered by surveillance cameras and -
you can't really fall off them yeah
you'd have to like climb up over the
road thing and all this other kind of
[ __ ] the other weird thing is that when
they found his body it was lying in the
water face-up and none of his um stuff
was going his shoes hadn't fallen off
like his shirt was still tucked in all
his jerk jewelry was still there all
this other stuff nothing that indicated
that he would have fallen all that way
and he didn't have any like broken bones
or any particular sign of trauma or
anything like that
so for a while you know the case was
just ruled an accident he had drunk he
fell in the river
whatever and then they didn't find him
until several months later it was the
cause of death drowning I guess so that
was the initial that was the initial
finding yeah but the family and stuff
like that and we're kind of like I don't
think so that seems very strange like I
said drowning victims are almost never
found floating face up I usually found
face down the body didn't look like it
had been in the water for four months
there were just other things like that
that seemed kind of weird now in 2006
the case was reopened and his death was
actually late then ruled a homicide and
this was due to some other like witness
statements and stuff like that okay so
the Jenkins family had hired a private
investigator and his name was Chuck
flesh and he was interviewing some of
the witnesses and things like that now
some people reported that a gang of a
bunch of guys had attacked someone on
the street like by this pizza place that
was right near the bar where he was this
is none of this I don't think came up on
surveillance footage or anything like
that but some witnesses said that they
had seen that he also got some canines
and bloodhounds and stuff like that and
they tried to find the Kris Jenkins as
sent and they followed his scent from
this kind of pizza place to this parking
garage and they actually found like a
red feather in there when and his
costume had had red feathers on it so
then they started to think well maybe he
got kidnapped yeah do him in a van or
something
yeah and then you know they they like
slipped him in the water elsewhere all
right but the weird thing was that there
wasn't really any sign of trauma on the
body or anything like that but they did
think that he had probably been murdered
now because of this particular case and
I should say this was kind of I guess
the one that kind of started the
interest in it because then these two
police investigators Kevin Gannon and
Anthony Duarte who were the two main
NYPD detectives that kind of started
this whole smiley-faced killer theory
they started looking back at all these
other cases like drowning cases
quote-unquote that were ruled accidents
and they thought that some of them
looked weird like that maybe some of
them might be homicides and that they
might be all related so okay it's got a
picture starting to come together yeah
maybe there's a gang of guys going
around drowning people or suffocating
them and making it look like that and
making it look like accidents that's
kind of a thrill kill Kult or something
yeah now here's the thing they surveyed
about my head it would take more than
one person to do it to do that's they
did you come up with that yeah and you
know they said there was a crowd of
people attacked a single man and now see
but the thing is too though that they
also had a statement from an inmate that
is in prison who said oh yeah I was
there
that night that Chris Jenkins got killed
and we killed him and threw him over the
bridge and now the private investigator
was like there's no way you could throw
a big athletic dude over the bridge not
just one person he's like it would be
hard for two people and Plus nothing
ever came up on the surveillance cameras
there someone would have seen that or he
wanted a killer I don't know okay so
basically Gannon and Duarte the two NYPD
detectives that kind of got interested
in this whole thing they went back and
examined a bunch of similar drowning
cases I think they did about 89 90 cases
that were you know similar and they came
to the conclusion that between 40 and 45
of these so-called accidental drownings
they thought were maybe murders weird
now this is what this similar
of it worth okay the victims were nearly
always college aged white males okay
almost always very handsome okay
very academically successful usually
athletically successful a lot of them
like Chris Jenkins but I think was a the
captain of the lacrosse team things of
you know football players lacrosse
players things like that all of them
went missing after a night of drinking
out with their friends whereas you know
at some point they disappeared and then
then they were later found floating in
the water these all happened almost all
except for Chris Jenkins which was
Halloween but they almost all happened
in the winter months which is strange
um when school is open yeah yeah right I
mean uh but none of them happened in
spring rose what they're saying most of
them happen December January February
what area is this and well this isn't it
that's the next thing I say okay here's
the thing it's a very very wide area
we're talking like from the Northeast to
the Midwest a lot of them Wisconsin
Minnesota Iowa New York State stuff like
that okay so it's not centered around a
city right it's not said it's like 25
different cities right 11 10 or 11
different states although they point out
that most of the victims were students
at colleges that are that are within 50
miles of the i-94 corridor okay so I
don't now oh here's another thing and
this is kind of why they call it the
smiley face killer murder theory is that
what these guys did was they used GPS
tracking and stuff like that and they
looked into all these cases and they
tried to determine using the river
currents and stuff like that where these
bodies had gone into the water rather
than where they were found and they say
that in at least 12 of the cases yeah
near where the body was put into the
water was graffiti of a smiley face huh
so they are positing yeah that there is
a serial killer or two of them or a gang
of them that are basically targeting you
know sort of middle to upper-class
successful white
college students either by their theory
is that the killer or killers are
motivated by jealousy okay yeah like
maybe they're ugly or they're not
successful or something like that and
they're kind of going out sort of
good-looking dudes but they think that
maybe that they're drugging these guys
or something like that because you know
there have been a couple cases where it
sounds unlikely just well that's well
that's what I mean it would have to be a
gang of guys going up and down that
corridor that was an i-5 corridor or I
94 994 corridor going to university
areas right and an abducted drunk guys
and faked faking their drownings killing
them and pretending that was drowning
yeah and then paint a smiley face at the
place where they put him to war right
it's just very unlikely well yeah well
that's what I'm saying but so like I
said it should be noted that most of the
cases like I think out of all the cases
that they say are possible victims of
this gang or whatever almost all of them
were ruled accidents at the time that
the guys were just drinking at the bar
they got drunk they wandered off and
fell in the river because it does happen
yes and people drown where you know when
they're drunk or whatever however there
was another case that's usually cited
that actually was that first thought to
be a drowning but then was later ruled a
homicide and this was the case of
Patrick McNeil now this goes all the way
back to 1997 and advocates of the
smileyface killer theory called Patrick
McNeil victim zero because he's kind of
like maybe the first one of this
happened and this actually happened in
Manhattan
the guy was 21 he was a student at
Fordham University and he was at a bar
called the dapper dog in Manhattan on
February 16th 1997 he went there quite a
lot witness accounts differ on how drunk
he was some people said he was pretty
drunk some people said he wasn't that
drunk he was evidently seen standing in
front of the bar for a little while as
though he was waiting for someone some
people said it was he was waiting for a
girl that he had met she was in the
bathroom or something like that but then
he sort of walked off by himself now
this case is interesting because
several witnesses reported that he was
kind of walking down the street and then
falling and stumbling and then walking
down the street and falling and
stumbling and some of his friends said
you know he'd only had a couple of beers
so they think maybe he got robbed now
some other witnesses also said that
there was a car that was like creeping
along the curb that every time he kind
of fell down stuff if the car would stop
right and then when he got up and
started walking that it was start again
yeah now they got a partial plate on it
but as far as I know they couldn't they
didn't investigate that any further or
anything like that
some people saw him turning left I think
on 90th Street or something like that
and the car also turned and after that
they didn't see the guy anymore
so he was disappeared everyone was
looking for him and stuff like that
they didn't find his body until April
7th and he was wearing only blue jeans
and socks and he was floating face-up in
the East River near the Brooklyn pier
now he was badly decomposed however
because there was not what they call a
skin slippage right some of the forensic
examination said that he probably
couldn't have been in the water all that
time that he had probably only been in
the water for a day or two as a matter
of fact so he's rotting up on land also
yeah also and this is kind of gross but
evidently there were like house fly
larvae in his pubic hair yeah which they
said that what those eggs would have had
to have been laid inside in a warm
climate because it was too cold outside
and they wouldn't have laid in the water
well somebody had him stored some so
yeah they're not and also I think also
the coroner said that the lividity where
the blood pooled that the blood was
actually pooled in the his the front of
his body even though he was found in the
river floating face-up right so he was
laying face down for a long time right
yeah also evidently he had some ligature
marks around his neck yeah that's it so
that's it yes so this was almost
definitely a homicide had to have been a
homicide
and so have a death did they know around
same time yeah not that's yeah I'm not
really sure about that because they
couldn't really tell like he'd been in
the cold water and there was partial
decomposition but then some of the
forensic evidence said maybe he'd been
burned like partially burned or
something like that
so there's kind of controversy there but
they're pretty sure that this guy had to
have been murdered and he was linked in
with a smileyface theory yes so so this
like I said you know when they went back
after the Chris Jenkins thing happened
in the 2000s they kind of went back and
examined other cases and they found this
one yeah you know that initially was
like oh he just fell in the river and
drowned after a night out of partying
because he had been seen kind of
stumbling along the street and stuff
like that but you know later when they
examined it closer it was obvious that
he had been murdered so like I said at
this stage they're thinking between
forty and forty five guys that were
initially thought to be drownings and
our murders there were a couple of other
ones too and actually if you guys
watched any of our 13 o'clock in minutes
videos and I did one that was about
creepy disappearances and there was one
that happened in 2006 and the guys name
was Brian Schaeffer now this guy is
unusual he has been speculated that he
was maybe a victim of this killer if he
kill her or killers if they exist
although this guy's body was never found
and this disappearance was very strange
this happened in 2006 it was the same
kind of thing where he was a med student
he had a degree in microbiology and he
was trying to finish a medical school
and he had gone out with his dad for
dinner he was like celebrating the
beginning of spring break you know cuz
he had just taken all his finals and he
was really tired and stuff like that so
he went out with his dad for dinner and
then he went out with a friend of his
and they went went out bar hopping and
he was last seen on surveillance cameras
going into a bar called the ugly tunas
Aluna - and yeah that's it - it is at
Alameda and he was never seen coming
back out which is very weird because the
whole area it was kind of a high crime
area so most
the businesses around there as well as
the saloon itself had surveillance
cameras well then that means he's still
in there well yeah some people think
that he might still be in there but they
I mean they never did find his ass they
didn't like report him missing until he
was supposed to fly to Miami on the
Monday with his girlfriend he was gonna
propose to her there might be more a
story then there may be more of the
story than we're being told like maybe
some of the cameras were down that day
or there's some gaps in the recordings
maybe he could have left you know I mean
and not been videotaped well yeah it's
obviously it's possible yeah they just
don't know offers they just don't know
as far as I know they've accounted for
everyone that they've see that they saw
on the surveillance footage and they
don't see him and they went in there and
they turned that place upside down to
fine-toothed yeah of course they did I
mean obviously obviously they would do
that yeah so they just don't know where
he went and the weird thing is that they
don't think that he disappeared because
some people think oh his mom had just
died if he was very upset about it he
was stressed about school and stuff like
that but it seemed weird that he would
commit suicide they and they never found
a body
and it seemed weird that he would have
run off on his own because his cell
phone and his credit cards and debit
card were never used again yeah so
they're imagining that he went somewhere
and got killed or either died
accidentally or got murdered and they
just haven't found him he must know that
the place in the crowd and the crowd
obscured him leaving on video listen
something like that you couldn't kill a
guy in there and then get him out
without being seen on video yeah and
then I don't think you could disguise a
guy and get him by the video camera
besides they were probably making sure
everybody who was accountable oh yeah
that's just that's just weird very weird
kid must be in by the way out of there
maybe he went to the bathroom and
crawled up in those tiles and it came
out in another platy they said the only
other exit at the time was like a
service entrance and they didn't see
there were cameras that it was there was
like a construction area behind there
and there were cameras kind of surveying
that too and they didn't see
try to skip out on this bill or
something and take up through the
ceiling tiles or something I don't know
that seems like a pretty desperate yes
maybe yeah he comes down somewhere else
you know in another part of the building
and he does leave and then somebody
murders him later on maybe something
like that it could be but like I said it
just seemed really weird and the the
creepy thing too this is also kind of a
creepy detail but that his girlfriend
she said you know what after he went
missing she would make a point of like
calling his cell phone every night just
you know see and she said it always went
to voicemail but then one night it rang
no one answered it but it rang must have
been an error and that yeah so she
called singular who was the thing and
they said yeah it was probably just a
glitch in the system and stuff like that
but she said she just kept calling it
over and over but like nobody ever
answered it but his cell phone was never
used his credit card sir never used so
they still have no idea what happened to
that guy and that was 2006 that guy
disappeared and some people have
speculated that he was a victim of this
theoretical smileyface killer
although if he was he's the only one
whose body was never yeah how did they
get him out of there right yeah I mean
there were cameras everywhere yeah about
that and like I said there's you know
there are so many cases and actually
when I was reading about this like on
various blogs and stuff like that some
people particularly in the Wisconsin and
Michigan area where a lot of these
disappearances and and deaths take place
are very adamant that there is something
weird going on because they said it
happens a lot like these sort of
successful handsome white college-age
dudes turning up drowned yeah so you
know that is not a statistical thing
well see that's and I'll kind of get
into that after the break because you
know there have been like the FBI and
stuff like that they've kind of had
their own thing to say about it but I
was gonna say that there are still cases
going on more recently that some people
are still attributing to this and I
think one of the most recent ones was a
guy named Zachary Marr and this happened
in February 2016 and that was in Boston
he was 22
kind of deal he was last seen at the
Belen hand tavern he was going out with
his cousin's for his birthday or
something like that now he was seen on a
surveillance camera he had gone outside
to smoke and you know they saw him
there's pictures of it clear as a bell
like of him standing outside the thing
and smoking a cigarette and his his
cousin had talked to him on text or
something he's like yeah I'm just
outside smoking I'll be back in a minute
or something like that but sometime
between 144 a.m. which is when the last
text came or when he was seen on the
camera and 151 a.m. what is cousins and
stuff got their coats and came out to
meet him he vanished they didn't catch
it on video no but see there's yeah
there's a pictures there's pictures of
him standing out in front now
he was found a few weeks later he it
looks like he maybe fell into the water
although again most of his most of the
people he was with and stuff like that
said he'd only had like two or three
beers and like I said some of these
bodies are found like a long way away
for are they disappeared like I think I
don't remember if it was Kris Jenkins or
Patrick McNeil but he was sound like 12
miles away alright now how far away was
that guy back from that from that puppy
was in what are they talking about miles
yeah I mean I don't really know I'm not
from there so I'm right how far away it
was but I mean I get I think it was in
within walking distance so was her than
walking this so I don't think he might
have gotten picked up but I'm just
saying that that there are cases like
this happening a lot and I think people
are you know every time this happens
particularly when something weird
happens like that we're like but you
know one minute you see them on a
surveillance camera just standing there
smoking or whatever and then like five
minutes later they're gone and you can't
really figure out where they went you
didn't see anybody picked them up you
know he didn't say where they were going
or anything like that it just seems
really odd and I think people are
latching on to that and particularly
like I said because all the victims are
the same I mean I think almost all of
them I think that a couple of them were
maybe Asian but I think up to 98% of
them 99% of them were white dudes in
their early 20s
college students followed them okay so
I'm gonna take a break right now and
when we come back I'm going to talk
about
Center for homicide research in the FBI
and stuff like that how they think this
is all [ __ ] and what they think is
going on so we will talk about that when
we return we'll be back in just a couple
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day at this house is very much
haunted and will continue to be odds of
a long time
okay so the smiley face theory now most
bear to say that most people in law
enforcement that have weighed in on this
theory do not think that it is a serial
killer or killers because it would
probably have to be more than one yeah
because you know they happened so far
apart and then to organize something
like that right everybody involved
quiets yeah it does seem far-fetched I
think so so the FBI has come out saying
they have looked into it but they don't
think there's anything to it and in 2010
the Center for homicide research put out
like a paper and it's called drowning
the smiley face murder theory and it's
available online it's about 12 pages you
can read it but they're kind of
debunking a lot of the things that
people say about this theory or make it
you know to make it seem like it's one
person or an organized group of people
even a loosely organized group of people
now one thing that people will say is
that you know statistically now there is
one weird thing this is kind of weird is
that all of these cases take place
almost all of them in the winter almost
all of them in the northern part of the
country now they're pointing out that if
these are all like accidental drownings
just drunk guys fall into the river or
whatever like that you think that it
would happen in the same numbers like
everywhere in the country like a down
south and stuff like that differences is
that the water would be very cold yes so
that might be in fact all right of their
death and another thing too as much has
been made of the smiley face graffiti
now the the original guys Gannon and
Duarte they said it was at least a dozen
maybe as many as 22 where they said they
found graffiti of a smiley face or the
word since inoue somewhere near the body
now I don't know what near means which
is kind of one of the bones of
contention right because here's the
thing the two guys use GPS and things
like
to trace where they thought the bodies
went into the water this is not an exact
science obviously so they don't know
exactly where the bodies went into the
water but when they looked around the
places where the bodies went away they
thought the bodies went into the water
they said they found smiley face for
this word which is actually a Native
American word and it's a pretty commonly
used like it's the name of several
businesses in that part of the country
and stuff like that so it's not as weird
as it initially seems cuz I had never
heard that word and I'm like what the
[ __ ] but apparently that's the thing
there the problem is that they didn't
really give an exact measure of how far
away this graffiti would have to be you
know I mean it's not like they find it
like right next to the body I like right
next to where it was done five hundred
yards away right it might be like you
know or it might be like a block away or
something like that
none of the we're statistically there's
everything within a block and to be
anything and now you can say yeah
toenail clippers there were toenail
clippers there involved because you know
every 500 feet right we found a pair of
toenail clippers right could be anything
you know and it wasn't found in every
case it was probably only found in like
maybe less than half of them none of the
smiley faces really look the same right
you know so like I said you know smiley
face is a very common maybe it could
just be that they're kind of doing right
and something else about the smiley
faces that I forgot to mention too is
that they don't know when those smiley
faces were put there it's like yes from
a you know a lab technical point of view
you can kind of figure out when that
paint was put on that wall of that tree
or whatever but it's not a super
accurate measurement like it's only
within about a year or something like
that so that graffiti could have put
been put there at any time right not
around the time of the murder it could
have been much earlier so you know
there's really no way of knowing like
when that turned up there there also an
same thing with the word like since
inoue which you know seemed weird to me
but they said no it's a pretty common
pretty common word and stuff like that
now some they've also pointed out while
some of the bodies had GHB in their
systems or things that you know but the
thing is yeah it's like one they don't
know if they administered that that they
took the GHB themselves right to the
body actually does produce produce
HP naturally in small amounts and also
produces it a little bit after death
also produces a little bit of alcohol so
there's no way of knowing how that got
in there if it was administered by
someone else or if they took it or if it
was just a natural byproduct so I think
kind of maybe one of the you know one of
the most reasonable things is like yeah
all of the the victim profile is similar
which does seem weird yeah but there are
a lot of guys but yes and here's the
thing because almost all of these and as
far as I know all of the ones that they
say are part of this you know theory it
was always guys that had been out
drinking yeah in a bar or at a party
young guys and then they left and then
they vanished and then they their bodies
turned up later and in their race I
think it's just statistical because if
you have a young guy that in college
drinking chances are he's white
especially in the Northeast yeah you
know I mean so when they drowned it
looks like they're a part of a group
yeah you could do the same thing
probably with hookers yeah yeah like oh
it's a statistically hookers die
certificate her hookers died in certain
ways yeah no I mean if you were to look
at all those hookers that died you know
in a common death 4-way hooker dies you
know on the job you could say oh there
must be one truck driver you know right
driving across the country
killing all this hookers all these ogres
no it's just statistical yeah and yeah a
truck driver is probably involved
because there's lots a lot most hookers
a lot lizards yeah they're in the damn
truck stops yeah well yeah because
that's where all the that's where they
are that's the way the business is and
if they get killed
chances are statistically it's a struck
driver because that's who they're
dealing with mostly truck drivers you
know they run out of wrong truck driver
kill him you know yeah he's gonna fight
over money or you know you stole some
from well and like I said in general
it's in general it's a very high yeah
high risk profession all right the drug
drug drug money's involved yeah and
we're constantly going with you know you
don't know and things like that so
evidently if you're a white student you
know college student in the Northeast
assists achill EU might end up in a club
and
statistically you might end up dead in
the water yeah well yes statistical
probability you know again like I said
people might be saying well there's so
many white dudes of a certain age range
and stuff like that but you have to
think that statistically white college
aged males they go out and drink they
drink to excess they engage in high-risk
behavior young males are you know way
more likely to engage in high-risk
behavior and some people have said you
know why does the same thing happen to
women why aren't we finding drowned
women turning up well I can tell you
exactly what it when it don't go out
alone as much women don't I don't think
they they drink as much to excess in
public or they don't go out by
themselves you know as much as a man
would but also they don't tend to engage
in the same types of high-risk behavior
whereas like you know a 21 year old
drunk guy might say I'm gonna swim to
Brooklyn you know or whatever you know
what I mean whereas like a woman would
not do that generally so you know so I
think there's some of that element to
and it should also be noted that this
most of these colleges where this stuff
is taking place where a lot of these
guys are students are kind of known as
big you know drinking party college
party colleges there's kind of
especially like in Wisconsin like in Eau
Claire and you know and you know
something else that the paper points out
is that in cases where there were where
police actually stopped a drowning from
happening or something like that is at
which they actually do quite a bit they
point out that a lot of these bars and
stuff like that are situated near bodies
of water and a lot of times the body of
water is downhill from the bar meaning
that if somebody walks out and they're
super inebriated then they're gonna walk
downhill cuz that's kind of the path of
least resistance and then you know
they're gonna fall in the water
like I said in some cases in the case of
Chris Jenkins in the case of Patrick
McNeil those were almost definitely
homicides but most of the cases that
these two detectives point to as
evidence of a serial killer are still
ruled as acts
and it doesn't appear that there were
signs of trauma
on the bodies as there were in the case
of Patrick McNeil and Chris Jenkins
which like I said had trauma on the body
or had other things about it that made
it seem like it was a homicide
yeah the fine thing about some of those
guys right there as you know I lived for
several years in Boston around those Ivy
League colleges and I used to go into
those bars all the time with bars and
taverns and some of those jock guys get
pretty loaded and they start throwing
their weight around and they start
treating other people inside that those
bars as if they're underclassmen you
mean and these are college students yeah
so the theoretically send these guys
could be going there throwing their
weight around around on guys that are
not college students and then when they
leave they follow them out and just beat
him to death or do something bad to them
so that's you know that statistically
can happen yeah and that you know that
can happen as well
it's just that I kind of feel like I
said could there be a serial killer and
I was actually watching another podcast
but I think it's called brain scratch
and he did like a two-part thing where
he was talking about this and he kind of
erred on the side of like I don't think
it's a serial killer either although he
said if it was something like that he's
like the only thing I could think of was
that there was some kind of site like on
the Deep Web where there was like a site
where people were killing these people
in this particular fashion just for this
like it was like a small coterie of
people like an underground type of thing
that we're killing these people and
leaving the tag the graffiti tag or
whatever and you know I said yeah that
seems possible weirder things have
happened but it does seem I mean I don't
think there's any way that it could just
be one person you know could it be -
could it be three I don't know and the
thing about it too is that in the two
cases in Chris Jenkins case and in
Patrick mcbeal's case I mean these
people weren't drowned on purpose they
look like they were killed in another
way and then put in the water as though
they were gonna try and wash away the
evidence or something like that they
weren't there is no known serial killer
who has ever deliberately drowned people
as like their method of killing them
they're like in pretty much all
homicidal
it's almost always apparent drowning
their children or a husband drowning his
wife like in the bathtub run no in the
overwhelming amount of cases there is no
case where a serial killer was actually
allowing people get back to we know what
the FBI's definition of a serial killer
is but a serial killer always is
basically a serial rapist that kills the
victim so you know I mean you have to
prove that there was a sexual motive to
say it was a serial killer there doesn't
seem to be a sexual motive in any of
these guys they're all found with their
clothes on pretty much and like I said
it's just it seemed like the only I mean
the only case where there was evidence
of you know torture or some kind of
trauma was the Patrick McNeil case from
1997 and we should note that he was not
drowned he was dead before he was put in
the water the other ones were drowned
it's so you know what we're getting to
is this is basically just a statistical
thing these these deaths all look
related but they're not in doubt you're
saying yeah I mean I'm kind of leaning
towards that I think yeah I don't think
they're related yeah and you know while
it is kind of strange that oh why
doesn't it happen as much in the south
or something like that but this paper
points out that it seems to happen more
in cold climates not just in the u.s. it
happens in the UK also and in
Scandinavia in places like that anywhere
where there's like young males that are
going out getting really drunk and you
know some of them are gonna toddle off
right and not and they also point out
that there might be an element of not
necessarily suicidal behavior right but
you know people who are super super
drunk maybe can get I think they call an
auto assassination where where where
you're like where if you just have a
fleeting like suicidal kind of thought
then you'll act on it without really
thinking it through because you're
really inebriated say so there might be
an element of that too like the person
might get pissed off or unhappiness I'm
gonna jump in here and [ __ ] and or
whatever's they said it might be an
element of that going on - and like I
said they point out that you know other
than Patrick McNeil none of the bodies
really had signs of trauma the none of
the men be beaten up you know or
anything like that which doesn't really
square with a serial
type of thing because the serial killer
I mean if you're gonna be a serial
killer
it seems weird that you would just like
drug a do it in a bar drowsy I'm just
drowning and not not doing they don't
steal any of their men raped a guy they
don't yeah there's nothing like there's
no other motive really right and it just
seems like I said is it possible like
you know like he said on brain scratch
that there's like this small group of
weirdos that kind of you know have some
little online community that are like
hehehe let's go like drown just job
jocks or something like that just seems
like an odd thing to do is it possible
sure but how long could you keep that
secret not long yeah and like I said the
you know the whole thing about the
smiley face in most cases they didn't
find anything like that and in the cases
where they did find it you they don't
know how long they were there they
didn't look like the same person had
made them or there there was no you know
there was no uniformity in the mine or
anything like one of them had devil
horns one of Bennett's tongue sticking
out one bro no they were all different
looking yeah and everybody everybody
paints with paints and writes with their
own hand if it was the same person
they'd be living eating his signature
behind that's what I'm thinking if they
wanted to be famous or they wanted this
to get out you think they would have
their [ __ ] together enough like half
like a brand or like a logo or something
like that because like I said there's
not there actually was a serial killer
called the happy face killer
he killed women his name was a Keith
Jesperson I think was his name and he
actually killed a bunch of women then
they called him the happy face killer
because he would write letters to the
police talking them with a particular
smiley face so he had like a particular
signature so this is not that guy this
is because he's in prison but so this is
this is a different thing and like I
said all of them look different there
are pictures of them people have taken
pictures none of them look the same all
right so I just kind of feel like I
don't know I feel like it's possible but
improbable it's improbable is all I'm
gonna say and I'm not saying like don't
yell at me like you know what I mean
it's like yeah and I know that there are
probably a lot more cases because like I
said when I was reading a lot of the
comment sections like under some of the
posts about it you know particularly a
lot of people in the Midwest and stuff
like that
man this happens all the time and like
some of them got to be murders and you
know it just seems kind of strange and
you know I'm not saying that it's not
yeah someone pry armors and yeah and the
thing is it's like once the theory
gained you know notoriety some people
might have like copycatted and like God
haven't done it then so like even if it
wasn't a serial killer before maybe now
like somebody's oh I'm gonna go out and
murder somebody like that just as I
heard about it you know I mean so there
could be a copycat element as well when
there wasn't one to start with
particularly because this case got such
a big you know particularly 2008 when it
first came out it kind of got a big
boost and I think it in 2015
stuff like that and you know I'm not
saying because it seems like the
original detectives they kind of had a
big heyday in 2012 you know the the
Gannon was on like a lot of shows and
stuff talking about it and he says that
he's spending a lot of his own money on
this investigation but some of the
family members of the deceased men are
kind of like not all that happy about
these two detectives I mean they're
pretty much saying we think they're just
like out for money or they're trying to
get you know notoriety or fame or
whatever and they think it's harmful to
the families involved now some of the
family members are adamant that they
think that their child didn't drown
accidentally that they actually were
murdered which fair enough maybe they
were um you know and they respect that
these guys are doing the work trying to
find out what happened to them
but you know there are some that are
just kind of like no I don't think I
think these dudes are just like latching
on to these families and trying to get
famous off of them and there's Boyden it
well there might be an element to I mean
they're retired like I said the Gannon
has even admitted that he is like
obsessed with this with these cases so
there might be kind of an element of he
wants it to be true Savelle agree has so
much invested in it that he's only
seeing things that back it up and not
seeing things that refute it which is
something that happens a lot when people
get this wrapped up in a particular
theory they're only going to interpret
things
that happen in light of that theory and
anything that doesn't square with it
they're just gonna abandon it so there
might be an element of that going on - I
agree with you I think there each one of
these cases is a different situation
they look to have something in common
just on the surface but it's different
things some are accidents some are
murders it's all different each one of
them and it has to do with just
statistically probably yes of how a guy
of that demographic how he could go and
yeah I mean and yeah a guy of that age
there's you know a healthy athletic dude
of 21 22 years old they're not usually
gonna die of like a heart attack they're
usually gonna die in a car accident or
this adventure or a misadventure they're
gonna go out drinking and they're gonna
fall officer Sanders that's what you see
and I think that's what you're seeing
and you know and they're not including
the guys that died behind the wheel they
were drinking and then died behind the
wheel on the way back home yeah they're
not including those because it doesn't
look similar yeah you know I mean but
it's the same thing yeah and like I said
some of these cases like I said the the
case about Brian Schaeffer the guy that
just kind of disappeared off the face of
the earth you know that they didn't see
on the cameras and stuff you know
could there be some kind of foul play
there you know I'm not saying these
cases don't have weird aspects to them
it's weird that like dudes would just
like wander off and vanish or whatever
without telling anybody where they were
going but I don't know people do weird
[ __ ] when they're drunk and they you
know maybe they just had an ideas like
oh I'm gonna go over here and take a
piss this is house and then fell into
the [ __ ] River this is how stupid I
was when I was in my twenties okay I
would smoke the cigarette would leaned
up against the the tail of my carbs in
Boston and at my feet was a manhole
cover they had slots in it yeah this is
1800s probably construction all right I
dropped something on the ground it was a
it was a pack of cigarette smoke back in
those days and when I leaned over get
that pack of cigarettes my Zippo lighter
fell out of my shirt pocket went down
and and hit that that manhole cover and
fell into the water underneath it oh
yeah I said well okay I'm just gonna
take this manhole cover off and reach
down there and you realize that is there
that
grab that lighter ya know so I didn't
take the manhole cover off but I found a
poll that was leaned up against side of
the thing and tried to take it off I
couldn't and then I shot shove the pole
down to see where the bottom of it was
and never could and I did work there he
worked with me it's nothing back my work
I said man I was gonna take that manhole
cover up reach down maybe even jump down
in there and get that lighter and he
goes dude that's about 60 feet straight
down my dumb ass you know I had jumped
in there to go get the lighter never got
me out of there yeah every bone in your
body you know they would they would have
thought that I was murdered yeah
somebody put him down in there no my
dumb ass my dumb 25 year old ass nearly
jumped out inside damn man over and it
pipe was you know maybe only three feet
diam but I don't think it could have
gotten back up yeah I mean that's yeah
but looking at it it looked like it was
only a few inches deep the water right
yeah it wasn't it went down forever
that's pretty scary yeah oppai but yeah
I think I mean you know I don't know
maybe it makes people feel better like I
don't know like I don't have kids and
stuff like that but maybe it makes
people feel better to know that there
was something I mean is that weird to
think that maybe it makes you feel
better to think that your kid was
murdered rather than just like drunkenly
falling off a pier or sometimes no I
wouldn't think I would think accident
would be easier to deal with yeah I had
many close calls when I was that age
just being dumb accidents yeah that's
what I mean so I I don't know like I I
feel like it's kind of weird to to think
oh well my kid was murdered and like
that would make you feel better than
this died but I was shot oh he does axis
[ __ ] happens I'm trying to tell myself
in this situation 20's and water and
cook my closest call I had when I was in
my 20s about water was the man whole
story yeah you know and it was just
crossed my mind to take that manhole
cover off yeah which is easier to do you
know T's you're said than done those
things are about 2 inches thick they're
higher yeah but I tried to get a stick
you know and pry it open
yeah had a prank had I pried it open
there was a chance I might have just
jumped in it cuz it looked like it was
shallow yeah you know I couldn't see the
bottom
I just assumed that hope they always
have the presence of mind is death taken
there down kill I did you know once I
couldn't get the lid off of it I stuck
the stick down in there and then as I
was an 8 foot long stick and it never
touched the bottom okay Cyril and a guy
I worked with a man that thinks deep
because yeah things got to go down about
60 feet probably seen seen it he saw dry
Oh certain times the year it went dry
yeah yeah so like I said I I think it's
more likely that guys you know frat guys
stuff like that they go out Friday night
Saturday night they get really really
drunk they're like I'm just gonna go
outside and smoke I'm gonna go outside
and pee or something like that and they
kind of have a little brain wave or
something like you do and they just kept
I'm gonna go over here and do something
you know and then they just fall yeah in
the in the water and they can't get out
and water's cold
yeah and you know like that that might
be why it happens more like in cold
climates yeah that point that that water
for a cold on takes few seconds you have
Thurman yeah yeah you just have like a
you have a heart attack if the water is
cold enough so yeah I'm kind of like I
said possible serial killer but I kind
of doubt it I think it's not likely yeah
very unlikely
so anyway that'll do it for this episode
about the smiley face murder theory it
was so cool story though it was like I
said I found it very interesting and
like I said a couple of them were
murdered oh yeah and they haven't solved
them yeah you know I just don't think it
was a serial killer I don't think there
are strange is that they appear on the
surface like maybe they were killed by
guys who knew them there was the dead as
involved money that kind of thing yeah
it's possible girls yeah so if you liked
the show remember to like subscribe
share all that other cool stuff check
out our Facebook our Twitter and all of
our other social media also go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com if you would like to give
a one-time donation there's a link over
in the sidebar or if you'd like to give
a monthly donation then check out our
patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast check out our latest
movie review which was the Omega Man
which is right here on this channel if
you haven't seen it
yet also good as zazzle.com / 13 o'clock
and check out our selection of t-shirts
if you would and also check out my new
book that faceless villain the audio
book should be out very soon and if you
wanted a free audio code just remind me
I've written most of your names down but
just in case I forgot anyone let me know
and it should be a week or two and you
should have your code maybe we'll do a
special show to launch that book 1 3
yeah maybe we should
okay but if that'll do it for this
episode and we will see you next Tuesday
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you